هذا واكد الحركه حماس انها لن تسمح
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي بتغيير المعادلات
وانها ستواصل الدفاع عن الشعب الفلسطيني
في كل اماكن وجوده وقال المتحدث
بحازم قاسم في تصريح صحفي ان توسيع
العدوان على الشعب الفلسطيني بقطاع غزه
يعد او بعد جريمه اعدام الشهيد عمار مفلح
في حواره لن يوقف ثوره الشعب الفلسطيني
حسب تعبيره
العسكريه لحماس كتائب القسام اعلنت فجر
اليوم عن تصدي دفاعاتها الجويه للطيران
الاسرائيلي في سماء قطاع غزه بالصواريخ
ارض جو وبالمضادات الارضيه
ينضم الينا من قطاع غزه مراسلنا وائل
الدحدوح وائل ما طبيعه الموقف الان وحدثنا
عن احداث الليله الماضيه
[موسيقى]
الوضع الان عاد الى طبيعته قبيل هذه
الغارات واطلاق الصواريخ من قطاع غزه
وما تبقى هو فقط اصوات الطائرات
الاستطلاعيه المسيره التي تحلق بين الحين
والاخر في محافظات القطاع الخمس بطبيعه
الحال وهي عاده همم مستمره من قبل هذه
الطائرات ولكن لا يوجد اصوات لطائرات
حربيه مقاتله همم حتى منذ ان نفذت
الطائرات الحربيه هذه الغارات في منطقه
خان يونس ورفح لم يكن هناك اي همم غارات
جديده وايضا لم يكن هناك اي رد فعل من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بعد عمليه التصدي
لهذه الغارات ولذلك يبدو ان الوضع عاد الى
ما هو عليه وهو الامر الذي يثبت من جديد
بان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اختار ان
يتعامل مع واحده من معادلات معادلات
الاشتباك السائده في قطاع غزه على مدار
الاشهر والسنين الماضيه باستثناء تلك
الموجات التصعيديه الكبيره او الحروب التي
شنت على قطاع غزه وهو الامر ايضا الذي
تبادله همم قوى المقاومه الفلسطينيه وعلى
راسها حركه حماس هنا في قطاع غزه يرفضون
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ترفض همم وضع معادلات
اشتباك جديده من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ولذلك هي تتصدى لاي محاوله من
قبل جيش الاحتلال لتوسعه هذه المعادلات
وخط معادلات جديده وعليه فان الليل الفاتت
انما يندرج في سياق مثل هذه المعادلات
السائده ليله امس شهدت عمليه قصف وشنغارات
من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على احد
المواقع التي تتبع لكتائب القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس في منطقه يونس جنوب
قطاع غزه هذا الموقع تعرض الى عمليه القصف
لسلسله بعدد من الصواريخ بشكل متتالي
بطبيعه الحال هناك اضرار جسيمه وقعت في
هذا الموقع لكن لا يعرف حقيقه طبيعه هذه
الاضرار والمنشات التي تم استهدافها داخل
هذا الموقع بطبيعه الحال هذا الموقع وغيره
من المواقع مراكز التدريب التي تتبع
لفصائل المقاومه تكون مخلاق في مثل هذه
الاجواء المتوتره خصوصا عندما يعمل جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن على اعلان اطلاق
صواريخ من قطاع غزه على الرغم من ذلك
الفصائل فلسطينيه لم تصدر اي بيانات ولا
توضيحات تتبنى فيها اطلاق اي من القذائف
وكان كانت الاحاديث تتحدث عن اطلاق قذائف
صغيره جدا همم
الفاصل الاحتلال قال بعضها سقط في الجانب
الفلسطيني ولذلك الاوضاع عادت الى الهدوء
النسبي في قطاع غزه